this chart shows which dogs are the most  popular in America you might want to  pause for Thought here why does it  change over time well a starring rule  seems to help when an endearing pup  called Snoopy made his debut in the  comic strip of peanuts beagles Rose to  fame and from 1953 they spent six years  as the most popular pooch  for labrador's repeated performances in  films such as Marley and Me have helped  the breed remain as top dog for the past  31 years  but few examples are more striking than  man's spotted best friend when Disney's  101 Dalmatians was released in 1961 it  caused a huge surge in demand which was  Amplified by re-releases of the film  right up until the 1990s since then  demand has plummeted  and the modern Frenchie Revolution well  that has been fueled by social media the  French Bulldog can thank celebrities  such as Lady Gaga and Reese Witherspoon  for posting selfies with their pets on  Instagram